er startet das gerade und vielleicht
skates und willkommen zu einem neuen
blog ich hatte leider gestern den ganzen
tag zu tun er sony und dann das setup
vom neuen pc
deswegen konnte gestern leider kein
video machen aber ich hab mir gedacht
das setup baut immer noch an deswegen
nehme ich einfach mal mit und zeige euch
so jetzt eins zu eins live wie das ist
sich jetzt den neuen pc einzurichten
wackeln bleibt man im bild so wie es ist
so der neue pc einzurichten weil ich
keine ahnung ich freue mich dennoch mega
bin ich so neue pc einrichten grafhorst
schwenken hier im hintergrund das plakat
so spiegelverkehrte könnt ihr mal in die
kommentare schreiben hat mir das kennt
mich wieder bei dem pc so da sind wir
das hinter dem pc auf dem boden liegen
hier mit der tastatur die ich gestern
schon gekauft habe so eine
standardtastatur 15 euro für super ganz
cool und multimedia tasten finde ich
ziemlich geil
und ja der pc worauf nicht echtes drehen
oder das ist weder das format macht dir
diese krassen ventilatoren ventilatoren
die kassen dürften einig und es
eigentlich ziemlich cool sind gamer pc
und jetzt wo ihr seht ihr den bildschirm
sind gerade im setup und wir klicken
einfach mal darauf dass ich die
lizenzbedingungen akzeptiere die
akzeptiere ich glaube ich aber sollte
ich kann euch eins sagen es war gestern
einfach so ein albtraum einfach so lange
gebraucht der gestern fünf stunden
versucht vom usb-stick zu booten und ich
habe es nicht hinbekommen
es hat einfach nicht geklappt und jetzt
habe ich wollte eine dvd kauft und hab
es dann so gemacht und jetzt
funktioniert scheinbar keine ahnung so
dass wir wieder er installiert jetzt
gerade keine ahnung wer das dauert hier
nebenbei auf dem alten laptop ein
bisschen musik ich muss jetzt mal die
ganze hier drüber reden damit es nicht
erkannt wird dass es downtown von
augusta sina und kitkat für allerdings
mal anhören wollen
hier bei dem der turm ist leider die
tastatur colandrea seht hier passiert
nix und hier ist cape drücke leertaste
muss stoppen sollte nichts passiert auch
hier alt f4 funktioniert nicht also der
die tastatur ist im arsch deswegen
switch mehr drauf und fanden raum mit
installation vor ort so weiter im text
er startet gerade neue gucke ich habe
wie so ein mega cooles motherboard oder
so keine ahnung
auf jeden fall stand der gerade neu und
was ich euch jedoch gar nicht gesagt
haben gestern abend bei ist krass ich
habe mal spaßeshalber den geupdatet 876
updates heruntergeladen hat zwei stunden
gedauert oder so die runter zu laden und
zu installieren das war die hölle
na ja auf jeden fall machen wir zwar
weiter hier er startet es gerade und
vielleicht mein gott jetzt handy fallen
lassen
vielleicht kann ich ja gleich noch
diesen blog auf dem neuen pc streiten
wer weiß so er lässt sich weiter zeit
hier mit der installation erschließt sie
ungefähr schon seit keine ahnung wie
viel minuten abnehmen
nebenbei in den ball läuft hier bisschen
dynamo auf soundcloud und ich hoffe
einfach dass er bald mal fertig macht
dass ich dann für etwas sind wieder
schneiden kann das mehrmals so leute da
sind wir jetzt er hat doch tatsächlich
geschafft das ding zu installieren
jetzt können wir mal dran machen hier
die wichtigsten programme zu
installieren erstmal die
bildschirmauflösung bisschen hoch setzen
da nicht diese behinderten schwarzen
ränder hat und dann mal ganz
bearbeitungsprogramm drauf damit wir das
noch geschnitten bringen so leute es
weiter im text installiert jetzt gerade
irgendwelche grafiktreiber ich hoffe das
funktioniert es hat heute leider
auf den 19 schon irgendwie falsch zu
machen oder das wir selbst gestand
deswegen absagen in tastaturen man geht
dann hoffentlich ohne will ich gern
wieder nach oben 30 gefallen hat dieses
kleine april so läuft was mit mir
passiert und dann würde ich sagen ich
freue mich auf